okay hi everyone
uh back for another episode of science
and technology
q a for kids and others
i noticed we have a question already
from mahmoud
asking about how alan turing cracked the
enigma code
well let's see how i can do on telling
that story
so this was something happened during
world war ii
and uh the enigma code was a code used
by the uh uh germans by the
axis powers um uh
and it was uh a code which they used to
send messages to like military
commanders saying
go attack this hill or to go do this
thing
um and the point was that if somebody
intercepted they were sending radio
signals
and uh if somebody intercepted their
radio signals they didn't want anybody
to be able to
hear or understand what they were saying
so what they did was to send
messages in code so they would send it
was using morse code which is dots and
dashes you know like like uh
i don't know e is a dot t is a dash uh
i don't know that much morse code s is a
um
dot dot dot um that was a way to inc
to um represent the alphabet
in a way that you could um sort of send
in a
like in a digital way except that we
didn't yet have computers and things
like that
but the question was if you just sent a
plain text
just almost ordinary uh pieces of german
whatever language then anybody who could
pick up the radio signal could
understand what you were saying
and if it says we're going to attack in
this place
you kind of don't want to go attack in
this place you don't want the enemy
um in that case the allies to understand
what you said so to speak um
because otherwise they'd be able to take
action on the basis of that so the idea
in
military cryptography is you want to be
able to
send uh orders and things in a way
that's encoded
so your enemy can't uh can't tell what
you're saying
so how did the germans actually do this
in world war ii
um they used this machine called the
enigma which such i think developed in
sweden originally
um and uh the machine is a
has a collection of rotors and what
happens is
that um you basically have
um you you it has a it has sort of a
keyboard like a typewriter
um and uh it's a it's an
electromechanical device
you press a button and like a like you
press an
a and then what happens is these rotors
move
into different positions and depending
on where
the rotors kind of end up that a is
turned into a v
let's say you try another a and that
will be turned into an x
let's say and and you and you go on so
the most naive kind of way that you
could um
uh encode a message um it's actually
often called the caesar cipher
it said that julius caesar used this
method of inciping latin in that case
not completely sure if that's
historically correct but it certainly
existed around that time
so what um the caesar cipher does
is you take a word like i don't know
ca t cat right what you do is you take
you remember the order of the alphabet
and you say
to each letter i'm going to add a
fixed number uh i'm going to add a
i'm going to make it increment a fixed
number of steps in the alphabet so let's
say it's two steps
so c would turn into d e
a would turn into c t would turn into v
so that means that cat c a t
would turn into let me get it right e
c uh v
okay so when caesar was sending his
latin
dispatchers to his generals and so on he
as it said would encode it by using
a uh a caesar cipher
where he would shift every letter some
number of places in the alphabet and
when you get to z it would shift back
again to a
and so on and then so what had to happen
was whoever received that
they would have to know how many letters
was it shifted by
oh it was shifted by five letters okay
then they can take the thing they
received
they just sort of subtract five they
shift back five places for each letter
and then they've got the original
message so that that
how many letters to shift by is called
the key
to the cipher the key to the the
cryptography
so the um the notion
so that's sort of a very very simple
kind of of
encryption is just you take the letters
you shift it over by a certain amount
now if you were given one of these
uh ciphers and you didn't know what the
shifting was by it's actually pretty
easy to do cryptanalysis to break that
code
how would you do it well one thing at
least in english i don't know what the
corresponding result is in latin but at
least in english
we know that e is the most common letter
to appear t is the next most common
letter
so if you know that everything has been
shifted by a fixed number of letters
and you look on at a message
and you see that uh for example
h is the most common letter then you
know
okay h is the encrypted version
of e and so that tells us how much
shifting there is
and we can go and apply that shift to
everything and we can decode everything
so that's a way of doing cryptanalysis
for a caesar cipher
so that was in in um in antiquity one of
the approaches was the caesar cipher
uh something that showed up i think in
the 1400s or something was a
so-called vignette cipher and that had
the idea
that instead of just shifting by a fixed
number of letters
what you would do is through the message
you would shift by progressively more
letters so for example
at the beginning of the message you
might be shifting by three letters then
the next letter you might shift by three
plus two
the next letter you might shift by three
plus two plus two and so on
and so that kind of scrambles things up
a bit more
but then by probably the 1700s 1800 or
so people
people knew how to break vignette
ciphers it's not too difficult
uh if you kind of think about things in
terms of probabilities and so on it's
not too difficult to break that
so then what happened by the 1920s 1930s
a um a common method of doing
uh encryption was by sort of a
mechanical generalization
of these kinds of caesar ciphers and
vineyard ciphers
and so the idea was that you would have
essentially these coat these wheels and
um
it's kind of like a thing with gears
where you would have these series of
rotors and they have
um and they are basically determining by
how many letters
to shift things but they're not just
going like in the veneer cipher it's not
just going up by a fixed number of
letters every
every time you get to the next place in
the in the message
it's changing the which letter to go to
by some much more complicated process
that depends on uh the way these these
gears work
and in the enigma machine there were
also some other things there was kind of
some electrical wires that connected
things to things which kind of
uh permuted around the different letters
and so on
but so the basic point was message went
in
in um you know in german it's typed in
it's kind of fun that there are
uh if you're if you're into the tourism
of enigma machines i have i have a
number of friends who have enigma
machines there
there there i don't know how many of
them were made but they're a decent
number that survived
um uh there's a good one uh the national
cryptology museum in in maryland
um this when i was last there had a
couple of uh enigma machines that you
could
type on yourself um it's kind of fun to
see how they work
um the uh in any case
actually the museum of math in new york
i think has an enigma machine as well
um the uh um
so in any case the the
the lingo machine was this thing where
you're typing in a message
it gets very scrambled um and
you transmit by radio the scrambled
message then at the other end
uh somebody has a oh i should have said
that on the machine
you're kind of making certain settings
that determine how those wheels
would uh um would kind of twist and turn
to get out the next letter
and so to decode the message you have to
set back up that key of how the wheels
would initially get set
so that you can then do the reverse of
the
encoding from the plain text to the
ciphertext
you can do the reverse to get back the
plain text the original message
from the ciphertext and so what would
happen is that the key
people would know oh on thursday we're
going to use this key
kind of like a password on thursday
we're going to use this password and
that information about
that on thursday that password is going
to be used that would have to be
distributed
in some way through couriers to actual
people going someplace or whatever else
um but so uh what would happen is
kind of every day uh the
germans would set their enigma machines
in um
uh with a different key and the british
would um uh be receiving all the radio
transmissions
it was easy to get the radio
transmissions you just said put a radio
mast in the right place
um and uh they would get the radio
transmissions and what they would get is
this
encoded message so it might be uh e q
z b d x y whatever it is
right that started as a piece of german
text
but then by being encoded by the enigma
machine it turned into this kind of
random
random seeming sequence of letters okay
so the the challenge on the bottom of
the british was
figure out what the key that was used
for that encoding was because once they
have the key
you can just put it into your own enigma
machine
and you can do your own decoding and
then you know what the message said
okay so so the challenge was find the
key
all right so what will be a naive way to
find the key well you might
say that you would just try all the
possible keys
and uh and figure out um uh what
um uh which key was used well there's a
problem with that just as there is with
passwords today
that um uh very quickly
there are just too many keys to try and
so
and in those days that was before
electronic computers digital electronic
computers existed
um it was a very slow thing to try the
keys so at first they would have people
trying these keys and so on
so okay so that you couldn't try the
keys
you couldn't try them every single key
you had to find
some way to use the fact that
the message would still have if you
could only
uh key in to the fact that the german
text
that was encoded was not random even
though what came out
seems random there has to be something
non-random about it because it's
encoding non-random german
text and so uh for those are into these
kinds of things the um the idea of
information theory which was um
uh talked about by claude shannon um uh
just after the second world war that
came out of kind of this thinking
about um what when you put in something
that isn't random
can what's not there has to be something
non-random
about the output because it's reflecting
this
this this non-random thing that went in
as the input and just
how much can you extract how much do you
need to know
um how how how much trace of the
non-randomness will there be in the
output and so on
well okay so what did uh
uh the people the british do
to break the enigma code so they had
this
operation at bletchley park in england
about about halfway between oxford and
cambridge
which are the sort of locations of the
the two top universities and in those
days in england
um they kind of had this place where
they recruited lots of people from
oxford and cambridge i
i knew some of the people who worked at
um uh
bletchley park many many years later um
and uh for a long time everything that
was done at bletchley park was
completely secret
um and uh nobody knew you know
uh people would say as one person i knew
who um uh had worked there
and who really uh gave a few hints
as i later realized about his work there
but would never say anything would never
have mentioned anything about the
details of what was done there met many
it took many years before the um uh the
work that was done at bletchley park
um which was the uh where where this
decoding of the enigma machines was
was uh made not not secret um
uh people say that the reason it was
kept secret for a long time
is because even though even after the
end of the second world war
um there was still a lot of enigma
machines in circulation used by many
countries
and um the british among others didn't
want people to know
that in fact the codes associated with
the enigma machines
could be broken and so that information
about what happened in the second world
war was
was not um was not made public okay so
how were the
the codes actually broken so
let's see how much detail um well
essentially the idea was to make
clever use of this sort of statistical
regularities
that existed in this seemingly random
output based on the fact that there were
statistical regularities in the in the
german
that that came in to the um uh
um uh to the to the uh
as the input but the actual process of
breaking these things
was partly done by machine and there
were these things called bombs
b-o-m-b-es that were made
that were essentially things that would
try and uh
not go through all the possible
combinations but would go through a sort
of specially selected
set of possible combinations that might
correspond to the key
and what was done in fact was there was
a the technology that existed in those
days as i said digital electronic
computers did not yet exist the first
of those uh started to be made right
after the war in 1946 or so
um the first serious ones at least what
existed at that time
were the uh switching systems of
telephone exchanges
and so in a telephone exchange an
old-fashioned telephone exchange
person a is trying to call person b and
basically
the wire from person a comes into the
telephone exchange
and it has to be connected to the wire
from person b that's going out of the
telephone exchange
and somehow you have to have this whole
device that's
that's making an electrical connection
between those things
and that was done using these all these
kind of rotor-like
things that would say this this this
number is trying to call this other
number let me make this connection here
um and so electronic switching um
uh telephone electronic switching
equipment was kind of convenient for
sort of making connections and trying
things out and so on
and that was repurposed to make these
kind of uh
early electronic type computers that
were used in blachley park
okay the story of alan turing how does
alan turing is famous
these days for having been sort of the
original conceptual creator of computers
um he worked as a young person at
bletchley park
and he had a particular role in um
uh in the breaking of um the enigma code
actually he worked for a man called jack
goode
who i met
years ago now and sometime in the 1980s
jack good was a statistician
a person who studies uh statistical
regularities of things
later on he also got interested in
biology actually he was most notable
perhaps in modern culture
for having been the person who i think
originated this idea of a singularity
where ais would get more and more
intelligent
and they would eventually get
intelligent enough that there would sort
of be this
infinite run of of uh increase in
intelligence but anyway jack good kind
of invented that idea but jack good was
was alan turing's boss at bletchley park
and um alan turing had essentially a
statistics problem
that was had to do with how you instead
of having to try all the combinations
how you kind of use statistical methods
to reduce the number of combinations
that had to be tried and that was his
his major contribution there he he also
worked on um
uh speech incitement actually um
interacted with claude shannon in the us
a bit
um and uh and and various other things
uh during the war but his
his his earlier contributions to
computing
were of a somewhat different character i
mean alan turing uh some of us
work on these big projects that last for
decades
alan turing was not a big projects
person alan turing worked on a series of
very
important small projects that lasted for
a few years um one of those projects
that he worked on in 1936
is the one for which he's most famous
these days is the invention of these
things called touring machines
um which are i mean alan turing himself
is actually really like tinkering with
actual physical machines
but the touring machine that he's famous
for is a is a is a conceptual abstract
machine not a physical kind of machine
that
that
people actually in practice build out of
things
and the question that he had was
if you were going to do a mathematical
computation if you were going to
calculate something or whatever else
how could you make a kind of general
uh kind of model of that process of
calculation remember computers didn't
exist yet
um people had um mechanical calculators
that just worked by um having kind of um
things a bit like a mechanical odometer
where you would have these
these wheels that would go around and
the wheel would go around
a whole revolution and that would make
the next wheel be a carry bit of one and
and so on and so on and so on so these
kind of electro
mechanical and actually by then
electromechanical
um sort of calculators existed but the
question was if you were able to do any
mathematical calculation you can imagine
how would you set that up as a kind of
conceptual type of machine and so
alan turing invented this idea of having
um essentially a a thing with a tape
where you would write down a series of
numbers on this tape
and then you just have this at the you'd
have the sort of the main head of the
machine
would just say i'm going to change one
of the numbers on this tape i'm going to
shift the tape left or right
and then keep going and then depending
on what number i read from the tape
i'll make a change seems like a very
simple process
okay the big surprising thing that alan
turing did
was to show that if you have a certain
machine that looks that works kind of
like that
you can make a machine that has that
kind of setup
where by having the right things
initially written on the tape
that machine can be made to act like any
other machine of that type
in other words it's a universal machine
you might have thought that to get
a machine that operates in a particular
way you would have to change the
hardware of the machine
but what he showed was just by changing
what you wrote on the tape at the
beginning
then you could make a universal machine
that would um
uh be able to
to do any computation one wants and that
idea
is what basically has turned into the
idea of software on computers
because the big idea of software is you
have a fixed computer you have your
you know your mac laptop or your windows
laptop or whatever
and it's a fixed laptop and you can run
any software you want you could be
running a
video conferencing piece of software you
could be running a word processor
you can be running all these different
kinds of computations they all run on
the same kind of hardware
it wasn't at all clear that anything
like that was possible until the 1930s
and until particularly alan turing's
work on turing machines
so that was sort of the big contribution
there what was a big surprise actually
was that there were a number of other
approaches
to thinking about how you would do
arbitrary computations
that looked very different there was one
called lambda calculus there was one
called
general recursive functions another one
called combinators
they were developed by other people and
one of the big surprising things was it
turned out all these different methods
that looked so very different
were all equivalent they could all you
could make a lambda calculus
thing that would emulate any turing
machine you could make any turing
machine
that would emulate any general recursive
function they were all could be
interconverted between each other and
that was kind of the clue
that there could be a general purpose
computer that could exist
now it wasn't clear that um i mean i'll
give two footnotes to this that are more
my personal contributions to these
things
so one of the questions was when you
have one of these universal turing
machines
how complicated does it have to be does
it have to does it have you know in the
the thing that's reading the symbols on
the tape
do there have to be 300 kinds of symbols
on the tape
and does the the thing that's reading
those have to some have some very
complicated mechanism
people thought um that the sort of
record was
that there would be four symbols on the
tape and seven states in the head of the
turing machine that record
was uh was gotten by a friend of mine
named marvin minsky back in 1962.
so from 1962 um until much later
that record that was the record for the
simplest universal turing machine the
simplest way to make
a sort of universal computer well as a
result of a bunch of science that i did
i kind of suspected there were
much much much simpler universal turing
machines and i found one
i found the very simplest possible
candidate which has
some just two states in its head and
three symbols that it can put on its
tape
three types of symbols it can put on its
tape and i i kind of came up with that
in the probably
mid 1990s i didn't know for sure whether
it was in fact a universal computer or
not then in
in 2000 um i put up this
prize for somebody to prove or disprove
that this was
the simplest this was in fact a
universal computer and a young chap
called alex smith in england
um in a limited number of months
actually came up with yes
he had this very complicated proof that
yes this particular thing is a universal
turing machine
so that means we we now know the
simplest
universal touring machine has just two
states three colors
um it's very very very simple thing it's
so simple that you could imagine you
could for example make a molecule
that would implement such a machine and
make a sort of computer
at the size of a molecule so that that's
some
one um uh one feature of of um
um uh so that was kind of uh part of the
end of the
of the turing machine story i think i
was going to tell you some other things
about i could tell you
a lot of stuff about alan turing and and
work that he did
and um uh but maybe if people are
interested i can do that but maybe i'll
i'll move on to another
another topic now um
okay there's a question from sarah here
can i explain
uh newton's actually i'm sorry i should
say one more thing
this idea about turing machines and the
idea that you can represent any
computation
as something that a turing machine can
do
is that was sort of an idea that emerged
from the work that alan turing did in
the 1930s
what we didn't know is whether in the
physical world
yes we can build a touring machine but
could we perhaps build a more powerful
kind of computer
could we perhaps build a computer which
even in finite time in one second let's
say
it could compute something which would
take a turing machine
an infinite time to compute we didn't
know whether that was possible in
physics or not
people suspected up through the 1980s
probably
that that actually would be something
that is possible in physics
and actually there even there are there
are both things in ordinary physics and
things to do with black holes
where it kind of looks like well yeah
you should be able to compute things
beyond what a turing machine can compute
actually my own work in the in the early
80s kind of made one
kind of think that wasn't so likely but
not so sure
but then recently as some these kind of
breakthroughs we've had in understanding
the fundamental theory of physics
i think we have really pretty good
evidence now
that no the universe just does turing
machine type computation it doesn't do
so-called hyper computation that is sort
of beyond what turing machines can do
and in fact that very fact that the
universe
only does touring machine level
computation turns out to be a
a critical central fact in understanding
how physics works
and what's possible in our universe and
so on but so that's kind of the end of
the story
when alan turing invented turing
machines he just thought
that he'd managed to show that among
touring machines you could have a single
universal turing machine
he had no idea that this would be such a
general
uh kind of uh thing in fact he himself i
don't think
believed that turing machines
represented what could happen in physics
when he did some work on physics he
thought that there was something sort of
very much
beyond turing machines going on in
physics i think he would have been
i don't think he would have been that
surprised actually but i think he would
have found it really interesting
to see that actually all the stuff in
physics
can be done with computations that could
be done with the turing machine
okay let's see on to the next question
here
um oh we got lots and lots here all
right
next question is from sarah here uh can
i explain
newton's second law of motion
okay so this is back in 1687
isaac newton uh was the person who kind
of brought
serious mathematics to physics uh
galileo had done some of this
a little bit earlier people like
archimedes had done versions of this
back in
in ancient greek times but um isaac
newton was really the one who
who very seriously brought kind of
mathematics
and in particular calculus that he
invented for this purpose
to to physics so the question was
could you make could you explain the
physical world
using kind of mathematical like
principles
isaac newton wrote a famous book called
his principia mathematica
that's just latin that's the latin for
mathematical principles
the full name of newton's book is in
translated into english
is mathematical principles of natural
philosophy
natural philosophy was kind of the then
name for what we would today call
physics
and what newton was really saying is
there are mathematical principles
there's mathematics that you can do that
explains what happens in the physical
world
before people like newton people really
hadn't had much of that idea they really
were just sort of reasoning
it's like you know aristotle for example
would say
things fall because they have a tendency
to go closer to the center of the earth
it's not it's not kind of there's
mathematics
that tells you that the rate at which
things fall is proportional to this as
etc etc etc newton had the idea of
bringing in
mathematics that was uh known
for lots of purposes of doing you know
calculating the area of a field or
working out you know interest for money
and things like this
mathematics was was known for many
purposes but newton really
sort of connected mathematics to the
physical world okay so what he needed to
do then
was to say if we're going to connect
mathematics to the physical world how
does the physical world work
so what was his model for explaining how
the physical world works
well in mathematics there are this idea
this idea of an axiom system
a system of rules that describe how
something works
so the most famous of those is euclid's
rules for geometry
so euclid's rules for geometry say
things like for example
if you have two lines that are parallel
they'll never cross
that's true if you have a if you're on a
plane for example that'll be true
or for example another uh thing would be
um if you have two points they um
you can draw a line between them or if
you i don't remember all of the axioms
but but um
they're things like that um and what
what euclid did
was from those axioms from those
statements about sort of how
geometry is set up he proved all these
facts he proved that you know
the the sum of the angles on a triangle
is 180 degrees
he proved um all kinds of other other
results he proved that there are five
platonic solids you know the
the all these kinds of things he proved
all these results
by using this kind of axiomatic system
that
he set up for geometry and i think
euclid in his time
thought that his axiomatic system was a
condensation a description
of how the geometry is set up in the
world um
well whether you know later on it became
clear through the work of einstein and
other people
that the geometry as the world sets it
up doesn't quite follow
the geometry that euclid said was the
way that that
one should set up geometry but anyway so
newton now in 1687
newton uh was trying to define
uh how the physical world would worked
and he wanted a kind of an axiomatic
framework
for defining the physical world and so
what he did was he came up with his
laws of motion which i think he viewed
as being very similar to euclid's axioms
very similar to statements like two
parallel lines never cross
but instead these were physical facts
like
newton's first law of motion is that an
object
not acted on by an external force
remains
in its uh in a
keeps going in a constant state of
motion
now actually that wasn't so obvious in
newton's time in today's world
if you oh i don't know have a um
you know if you have one of those uh i
don't know air hockey tables or
something where you've got
something a little puck that has very
little friction and you push the puck
the puck will just you know you push it
with a certain uh
force it goes with a certain speed we'll
just keep going with that speed it won't
get slowed down by friction
if there is friction it'll slow down and
stop in newton's day
there wasn't a lot of stuff that didn't
have friction but nevertheless newton's
dead if you could get rid of friction
then it would be the case that any
object if you just set it
in a certain state of motion with a
certain velocity it will just keep going
with that velocity
and it won't go it'll go in a straight
line forever
now in um uh you know in space
away from the gravity of the earth and
so on yes that's how it works to set a
spacecraft
it'll just keep going um and so that's
newton's first law of motion
newton's second law of motion is that if
you act on something with a force
then there's a formula that says the
force you act on it or
act on it with is equal to the mass of
the object
times uh its acceleration so that says
that if you if you push something with
some force you can
make the thing accelerate so take that
formula
you can switch it around it says the
acceleration is equal to the force
divided by the mass
so that means if you act on something
with a force that force will cause the
thing to accelerate
you push something it'll accelerate
so that's that's newton's second law
force is equal to mass times
acceleration
um and in a sense that law can sort of
be thought of as the definition of force
but it's also a a statement you can you
can have other
ways to sort of characterize forces
newton's third law is the statement that
to every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
if you push on something there will be a
if
if the thing is going to then then
something will
it'll sort of push back on you in other
words there's sort of an equilibrium of
forces that can happen
if you if you have a system that somehow
is is
initially in a in a in a certain uh
stationary state then a force pushing
one way must be opposed by a force
pushing the other way and sort of famous
example
if you're um the famous example if
you're uh
for somebody like me who's who's utterly
inept with these things if you do
skateboarding
don't i don't don't look to me to
actually be a practical doer of that
but um if you do skateboarding then if
you
uh sort of uh jump off your skateboard
um your skateboard will go in the
opposite direction um
and that's that's a consequence of
newton's third law um
to if if sort of things are in a
stationary state to every action as an
equal and opposite reaction
so newton's laws were kind of the
axiomatic laws
that governed uh the the mechanics
um of that was the ways of computing
things in accounts to that he added one
more fact
which was his universal law of
gravitation which said that the
gravitational force between two objects
is proportional to the mass of one
object times the mass of the other
object
divided by the square of the distance
between the objects the inverse square
law
multiplied by constants called the
gravitational constant
um that uh is an overall proportionality
constant that tells you how how large
overall the force is so with those three
laws of motion
plus his universal law of gravity
newton was able to compute in principle
at least
all kinds of things about the motion of
planets and comets and all sorts of
other things
the actual computations were difficult
he invented calculus as a way to
actually apply those laws
to to represent for example a very
typical thing in calculus is
you know that something is accelerating
uh that it something is accelerating has
a certain profile of acceleration
accelerates very fast for a while then
it slows down its acceleration
speeds it up again okay how then what
does that mean for where the object got
to
so for example something that falls
under the gravity of the earth
it has a fixed acceleration that's the
acceleration due to gravity
about 9.8 meters per second per second
that's the
the acceleration is the rate at which
the speed of the object increases with
time
so that 9.8 meters per second per second
means that every second
an object that's falling under the
earth's gravity increases its speed
by 9.8 meters per second at least it
would if there was no air resistance and
so on
um so but but if you know that you know
it's increasing its speed at that rate
the question you can ask is so how far
does the thing actually go
and to do that you have to work out uh
in calculus you would work out an
integral
um actually galileo even before calculus
had managed to figure this one out
that the the distance gone is
proportional to the square of the time
um uh the the under with a fixed
acceleration like the acceleration due
to gravity
the distance the object goes is the
square of the time it's been it's been
falling for or whatever
okay so anyway that was that's that's
kind of how newton's laws work
and newton had figured out famously
figured out um
the elliptical orbits of planets based
on those laws
uh the orbits of comets um and he tried
to figure out things like the orbit of
the moon
but it turns out just the calculus the
the all the different effects there and
all the different pieces of the
of the formulas that you have to get
it's just really hard to work out just
the math is really hard to work out
it took another 150 years before that
was was decently worked out
even though the underlying laws that
newton had were perfectly
correct for that now newton's laws
continue to be sort of the laws
that represent motion they had a
correction
in 1905 einstein's theory of relativity
and then his general theory of
relativity in 1915
produced some corrections to those laws
so newton's law says
force is equal to mass times
acceleration actually
it's um that's corrected to be mass
divided by square root of one minus the
speed squared over the speed of light
squared
and there are a few other kinds of
corrections that get made to these
things
um that are the consequences of
relativity
um and uh well that's not um there are
there are some very subtle corrections
to these things that we expect to be
the case as a result of our new theory
of physics they won't be things that
will be immediately observed in ordinary
everyday physics
they might be observed in situations
close to black holes where there's very
intense gravitational fields very
intense gravity
um but won't be an everyday thing but so
that's the story of of newton's second
law
okay let's see a question from just
nueces how much of science has kept
secret either classified by the military
or waiting for monetization inside
private research labs
it's an interesting question i mean in
the course of my life i can talk about
things where i've known
what's happened what's not happened on
that uh
you know one of the questions is is it a
good idea for everybody to know
everything about what's happening
in science and what's been discovered in
science sometimes it seems like a pretty
bad idea
for example nuclear weapons how do you
make nuclear weapons
um well you know the more people that
know that
the more nuclear weapons will get made
and probably the more dangerous of a
place the world is likely to be
so that's something which has been um
some aspects of that have been kept
classified
kept classified as secret by the
government um
uh for a long time ever since the
nuclear weapons were first developed in
the in
1945 um the
so that's but it's mostly i think
details that are secret there
i think there are things about i don't
know how do you make an x-ray laser i
think they're probably secrets around
that
still um the uh um
there are there are places where people
for a long time have thought this better
be secret because otherwise
it's a problem um an example one of
those is in cryptography
in making coded messages people had the
idea that
if you want to have a code that is hard
to break
people have to not know how the code
works and that idea persisted
pretty much through the 1970s even into
the 1980s
and then it became clear that there were
reasons that a code could be hard to
break
that were just mathematical reasons even
if you knew completely how the code
worked
if you didn't have the key that would
break that particular
instance of the code you still couldn't
get it just for mathematical reasons so
the idea
that you had to keep code secret pretty
much disappeared
there are other things um there are
other questions like for example a good
question is
is it a good idea to have if you knew
the genetic sequence for a really nasty
virus
that would cause a a you know a a
terrible pandemic even worse than the
one that we're in right now
um should that be kept secret should not
be kept secret
um and and how should that be done and
so on i think many people would argue
that that
was a good thing to keep secret because
it's just not that hard to synthesize
you know eventually to synthesize a a
simple virus
um so that's an example of something
that sort of should be kept secret in
terms of
what has been kept secret and has become
not secret
i would say that the the vast majority
that there is to my knowledge over the
course of my
career i'm thinking what pieces of basic
science were secret and then became not
secret
there are some around nuclear physics
there are some around cryptography
i think essentially all the pieces of
basic science are now
uh not secret anymore um are there
things that companies know about how to
do things
that are secret yeah there are certainly
ones of those
trade secrets of companies and so on
about how
to make certain things work i think
those tend to be more matters of
engineering of you know how do we in
detail make this piece of code work how
do we in detail make this device work
how do we in detail put ingredients into
this particular
you know drink or something um those are
more details than they are basic science
i i don't
think i'm maybe i'm not remembering
something but i don't think there's all
that much basic science
that ends up being kept uh being kept
secret
i mean i think that the um uh people
sometimes have um
uh all kinds of wild theories about
pieces of science that have been kept
secret
um i've never really seen any any good
evidence
of um uh of of those things now there
are
there are you know sort of strange
secrets in the world like you know who
invented who was the
who is the person behind you know the
bitcoin cryptocurrency and things like
that
there are secrets like that um but those
are more secrets about
the doing of things or the details of
things than they are about
the actual basic science of things
let's see oh gosh all kinds of questions
here
um
uh there's a question here from lantunes
how can we understand the double slit
experiment with light
um if lights made with particles whose
quantum wave functions interfere
etc etc etc um
uh okay well let's see where do we go
with this so first of all let me explain
what the um um
let me explain something people may or
may not have seen so if you if you drop
a stone in a pond
you'll see a bunch of you'll see a bunch
of circular ripples come out from that
stone
hopefully people have seen that that's a
sort of a circular wave
that goes ripple ripple ripple it's
going the waves so that the ripples will
go
up down up down up down a circular
pattern
okay okay now imagine you drop two
stones
in the pond at the same time you'll get
two patterns of two circular patterns of
ripples
but somewhere in the middle those two
patterns of ripples will interfere
there'll be there'll be places in the
water where there's ripples from one
stone and ripples from the other stone
what happens there so what happens is
whenever
the the sort of the the up piece of a
ripple
um meets the up piece of the other
ripple you'll get a double height ripple
whenever you get two down pieces meeting
you've got a double down
piece of ripple but when you have an up
ripple from one side and a down ripple
from the other side
then you'll get um then they will
destructively interfere
and that particular piece of water will
be flat so that's the phenomenon of
interference
between waves okay the same thing
happens with light
and people have wondered for a long time
is lighter like more like a particle a
stream of photon particles
or is it more like a wave and in fact in
the theory of quantum mechanics
it's kind of a mixture of a wave and a
particle you can view it
in a different sort of mathematical way
you can view it in either one of those
cases
viewed as a wave it uh this sort of
rippling effect and interference between
ripples
is what you expect and you have
interference in light
even in terms of particles it's not so
clear
how that interference works because like
well two photons meet
and why do two photons you know you
think you have two photons meet you get
two photons
well sometimes you get actually zero
photons they destructively interfere
okay how does this work well there's a
mathematical theory of how it works in
standard quantum mechanics
in our theory of physics we actually
have a real explanation of how
this works um which is something that is
sort of very new
and let me see whether i have even a
hope of being able to explain this
all right let's give it a try so
in ordinary physics one of the things
that one
thinks happens is that
you you have a a ball
it's thrown in a certain direction the
ball follows a particular trajectory
it just goes and whichever way it goes
in quantum mechanics
there's a different picture instead of
there being a definite trajectory for
the ball
there actually is a whole collection of
possible trajectories like at every
moment
the ball can choose many different
directions to go in
and there's this whole network of all
these different directions the ball
could go
and these different directions you could
for example the ball could go
one way it could go the other way and
then later on it could go
back that way back this way and then in
the end
even though it followed two different
paths the ball could end up back in the
same place
okay that phenomenon of what we call a
multi-way system
is this phenomenon of tree of going to
all these possible possibilities
we call that a multi-way system because
it it follows all these different ways
of going
all the possible ways of going okay so
an important feature of the multi-way
systems that we think
correspond to physics is that any time
there's a branch
any time it can go in two different ways
there will always be a merging of those
two branches
uh it's a phenomenon we call causal
invariants for reasons that are
a little bit um difficult to explain but
but um
okay so so anyway any any time
it branches it merges these possible
parts of behavior
okay well this notion of all these
different possible branches
these are not branches happening in
physical space
in the space that we know about it's
possibilities of how
things work in a in a different kind of
space we call it branchial space
the space of possible branches and um
the what we humans
this again is a little bit hard to
explain we humans
exist in this kind of multi-branching
uh uh world
and we too are showing these kinds of
branchings and our whole
perception of things is based on we're
branching the world is branching
we kind of when we untangle this we
realize
that we are sort of we are sensitive
to a certain sampling of this kind of
elaborately branching uh sort of in this
in this branchial space
we are sensitive to uh sort of certain
we we are just as we are localized in
space we exist
but you know i'm in this particular
place so similarly in branchial space
our perception of how the universe works
is sort of
roughly localized in bronchial space
it's not quite right but it's it's a
good
good first approximation okay
so what happens in
the case of these photons these photons
they may be moving in physical space
but they're also going through all these
different paths in bronchial space
and what ends up happening is that
essentially when we
are observing uh a photon
arriving somewhere we are localized in
bronchial space
and these photons that might go in these
two different directions
they basically never reach us in
bronchial space this destructive
interference phenomenon
is essentially the result of the the
these photons going to different places
in bronchial space that are far from
where we detect them
not in physical space in physical space
the photons might be in exactly the same
place
but in bronchial space they're in
different places this is
slightly hard to understand and i'm
condensing a lot of kind of new physics
that we figured out but that's kind of
kind of how that works um
and uh uh gosh a lot more to say about
that
all right let me try and address a few
more questions here from alec
why does no time pass at the speed of
light
oh well um
let's see so
let me explain what what is it we
understand this much more clearly in our
new theory of physics
um although in this respect it's
actually maps
well into existing theories of physics
okay um the question is how do we
perceive
anything to happen in the universe in a
sense we can imagine that
in the universe there are lots of events
happening
those events happen we can say they
happen a certain place in space they
happen at a certain time
but basically one event and the event
could be i don't know a particle
disintegrates the event could be
two uh two things collide i don't know
all kinds of events
but one thing you can definitely ask is
uh which event
in order for a particular event to
happen which other events had to have
happened before it
in order for it to be able to happen if
you think about it in terms of
computation it's like you are computing
something
what inputs do you need to your
computation that were outputs from a
previous computation
okay so tricky thing is if
you are looking at what things depend on
what a particular event what can it
affect
in what can it subsequently affect
well that event is it can affect things
that happen
at the same place that it happened later
in time but what about
something on the other side of the
universe can the event that happened
here
affect something on the other side of
the universe well
no not immediately because the speed of
light
is the maximum speed that that anything
can travel at
and in order for a particular event here
to affect something
far away there has to be information
about that event
that travels to the place far away and
the maximum speed that that can
travel at is the speed of light okay
so the the thing to understand is that
in the end
there's this kind of causal graph this
causal network
that's built up in the universe that
says this event happened
its effects propagated at the speed of
light to other places
it could affect these other events but
eventually there's this causal network
that says this event affects this event
affects this event and so on
but in a sense for and we
are part of that whole causal graph of
of events
our brains are sensing there are events
going on in our brains
that are the result of events that we
observe elsewhere and so on we
we see something happen and so something
happens in our brain as a result of
seeing that we think this thing whatever
else
okay so what what happens then is that
the um the thing that uh so so
uh this we have this we're part of this
causal graph
of what connects to what and everything
that happens
inside us and what we sense in the
outside world and so on
it's all limited by the speed of light
the the sort of the edges in this causal
graph the
the how an events are connected to
events um
they those things if we were to say
you know after a certain time elapses
the maximum distance away that an event
can
be is the speed of light multiplied by
that time it's the distance light could
go in that time
okay so then what happens
well essentially if if
if time is going to pass if we are going
to perceive
time as having passed that will happen
because
lots of events have happened for us
we've got lots of things have sort of
gone on for us we can tell
time passed things happened
okay but but now what what happens is if
you are
on um if you're going at the speed of
light if you're
so yeah if you're going at the speed of
light essentially you don't get
kind of the the the um you don't get a
chance
to think about to to have other things
happening
the the only thing that can happen is
that you're moving
through space as quickly as you can so
the things that represent the passage of
time
sort of can't happen for you because
you're putting all of your
all of your sort of everything that
happens to you is devoted to moving in
space
you don't get to use any of the
what we think of as computation actually
that is going on inside you don't get to
use any of that computation that's going
on inside you
to to have sort of time progress
instead you're using up all that
computation to essentially move in space
that's a very rough way of understanding
um why it will seem to be the case that
if we were going at the speed of light
in order to move at that speed we kind
of have to use all our computation just
in moving
and so we don't kind of perceive any
time to have past
now i should have perhaps said at the
beginning that in special theory of
relativity
in relativity theory um that has the
feature that
uh time slows down as you go faster
so the the apparent for us
looking at something that is going at
the speed of light
it will going very close to the speed of
light the apparent
rate of time will be slower and slower
and slower as the thing approaches the
speed of light and right at the speed of
light it'll just freeze
and no time will seem to have passed
so somewhat confusingly i mean if if if
we were photons
uh particles of light and we were
created at the beginning of the universe
the universe became transparent to
photons around
uh um a hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe
from that time until now a photon could
have just been traveling at the speed of
light through space
and if we were somehow existed in that
photon if our consciousness if our
brains
were in that photon so to speak
traveling at the speed of light
no time would have seemed to have passed
from the beginning of the universe until
now
and that's that's a feature of the sort
of all of the computational effort of
the photon
in some sense is spent having it move
through space
and it doesn't sort of have the
opportunity to use that
some of that computation to make it kind
of progress with time
i mean that's a a very um it's a bit of
a
actually what i just told you is a
is a more more of a genuine explanation
for this phenomenon called time dilation
than one really has has had before
um i mean that's based on sort of uh
some indications of this
this theory of physics that we have
before what people have said is
it's just an axiomatic fact that the
speed of light is constant and then
from that it follows a bunch of things
and you can deduce that it has to be the
case that there's time dilation and so
on
what i've tried to give you is a little
bit more of a more sort of mechanical
explanation of why time dilation happens
um
let's see oh gosh so many interesting
questions
um unfortunately i'm kind of running out
of time here but um
um
let's see all right we got a
couple of fun questions that i might
try and talk about so there's a question
here i talked earlier about alan turing
uh particularly in connection with the
breaking of the enigma code
um and someone said computers were
inspired
by turing's work that's actually a
complicated piece of history
so alan turing in 1936 proved that as a
mathematical possibility
there were these so-called universal
turing machines it was possible to have
a fixed mathematical model of a
computational device
that could at least do all the
computations that any
mathematical model of that type could do
okay so that was sort of thing number
one thing number two
people had electromechanical calculators
which did particular calculations you
know
they would work out square roots they
would work out this they work out that
people have thought about actually
mostly a couple of people
in the 1800s in the 1840s and things
had thought about the idea of taking
these at that point purely mechanical
calculators
and somehow making them programmable
kind of the idea this was an idea of
charles babbage and ada lovelace
of being able to have punch cards
cards where you just punch out holes and
there's a
sort of a mechanical device that senses
where the holes are
and you could kind of use that
mechanical device to determine
which wheels which cogs would engage
with which other cogs
to determine what calculation would be
done by this mechanical device
and particularly ada lovelace had a
pretty good description back in the
1840s
of kind of conceptually how one would
make what in those days they called an
analytical engine
um that would be able to take uh
programs they didn't call them programs
in those days
um that um uh to describe how different
computations could be done
well the general idea that that
analytical engine was never built
would have been the size of a large you
know train locomotive in those days
and it would have been a very expensive
object and the project was poorly
managed and
it's a whole long elaborate story that i
whose history i happen to have studied i
could tell you about in great detail
it's an interesting story of people and
um it's kind of a
in the end it's a sad story because ada
lovelace um
who i think under charles babbage was
more of an engineer ada was more
somebody who was really just
thought of herself as an expositor of
what was going on but basically she
understood more deeply
than than than charles babbage did sort
of what the real point of this
analytical engine would be and she wrote
this very very nice um
uh uh essay about it famously saying
in in traditional victorian english you
know the analytical engine will
weave algebraical patterns um
much as the jacquard loom you know
uh weaving machine will weave pictures
of birds and flowers
um her algebraical patterns she thought
of
she thought about computer generated
music she thought about
all kinds of mathematical calculations
and so on as algebraical patterns in her
victorian english
um but any case so so that idea was sort
of around
um people have been building these
mechanical and electromechanical
and even electrical electronic computers
electronic calculators that would do
just mathematical calculations work out
square roots do this do that
okay then around in the 1940s by the
beginning by about 1940
people um began to have the idea that
maybe you could have
a calculator an electromechanical
calculator
that would be somehow programmable that
instead of a person
setting up how the cogs would be set up
and how the connections and the wires
would be set up
there would be some automatic way to do
that a chap called vincent atanasoff was
a famous one
who had as a physicist who um who set up
a kind of an
early machine that did that but um so
there was this kind of whole tradition
of um sort of well it's it's it's
something where well you could set it up
by hand but you could kind of automate
setting
setting up the calculation and that was
kind of emerging as a way to do
computation
so by the end of world war ii uh 1946 or
so there started to be machines that
were
uh more in a more streamlined way had
sort of stored programs that would
be the things that set up the
calculations they would do famously one
called the aniak
built in in uh philadelph near
philadelphia pennsylvania
um the um uh
and that was so there was this whole
idea of kind of this
you could set up a computer and you
could give it these instructions that
said you know add numbers multiply
numbers do this do that
do these calculational things alan
turing's
mathematical turing machines didn't have
things like arithmetic in them they were
much more
just conceptually you can compute things
you'd have to build that up
um build up arithmetic from lower level
constructs
okay so in fact those two traditions of
practically making electrical
calculators
and and practically and thinking about
the mathematics of computation
were really two different traditions
they strangely merged
in in 1943 i guess
there were these chaps uh warren
mcculloch and walter pitts
who were kind of trying to make a model
of the brain
and they knew that the neurons in the
brain were electrical
and they thought aha you know these are
electrical we've got these
electrical calculator-like things
uh and you know is the brain like a
giant calculator
oh but we've also got this idea of alan
turing's over here
about how you can make a universal
thing that's sort of in a calculator
like we're made up of wires and things
like that
and so they showed that their kind of
conceptual model
of how brains worked with you know wires
for neurons and things like that
could be universal in the same sense
that our insurance
turing machine was universal so they
kind of brought together that at a sort
of mathematical level and
in those days particularly fields like
uh psychology psychiatry and so on
were really uh sort of leading the
charge in science in certain ways
and so it was very uh it was a very very
hot area
um and this was the thing that was done
as a sort of matter of
in a sense mathematical psychology you
could call it
so okay so that happened there was a
model for the brain
so then what happened was uh
particularly a chap called john von
neumann who was a
mathematician primarily um uh who um
uh i've heard many stories about he died
before i was born but i
i've known many people who knew him um a
very very quick fellow
who would always be able to sort of
answer problems quickly anyway
he came in as a consultant actually to
ibm
about how to make computers he famously
made various
predictions like only the world will
only ever need five computers
which turned out not to be a great piece
of uh foreseeing the future
um he also i think had um uh were
various other predictions which were
which were interesting mistakes i mean
they were
they were mistakes because of just not
foreseeing uh
how things would play out and what would
be possible and so on
but any case so through him and and
other people around him this kind of
idea about how brains worked which had
made use of alan turing's work kind of
merged with the sort of practical thread
of let's just make electrical computers
um and that sort of that became
something where there was a more
slightly more theoretically based
approach to making computers i mean the
earliest computers
were made primarily for ballistics
computations
um originally they were made to compute
uh you know you
fire a big gun and you point it up at a
certain angle
and it's going to fire a shell and the
shell is going to go 10 miles
where exactly is the shell going to land
given air resistance given the rotation
of the earth given all those things
to work that out was a job for a
computer
before there had been electronic
computers there were people
who would be actually carefully
calculating you know by hand
all of these different you know the wind
velocities this do this do this do this
actually they would have ballistics
tables but when they were dealing with
more elaborate calculations of you know
a gun that had never been fired before
or a missile that was going to be fired
something like that
it was a question of you know human
computers uh usually they got spelled a
different way
computer the electronic thing is is an
er at the end i think the
the humans often themed themselves with
an or at the end computers
um and uh there were there were lots of
people who
who did that it was a it was a kind of
common um
activity in fact my my friend physicist
dick fineman
was in charge of the human computers who
worked on the manhattan project
uh for building um the first uh the
first atomic bomb
in during world war two um and and that
the calculations for that were all done
by
human computers so to speak not by
anything um by by they had mechanical
calculators and things
but um uh not um
not by our modern digital computers so
that's kind of the story of that
um
well the uh yeah uh someone's commenting
on ada lovelace
as being the first programmer yeah i
think that's a fair i i have studied
this history in quite a lot of detail i
think that's a
a fair thing to say she had a she really
wrote out in her sort of exposition of
the analytical engine
she wrote out this is what the um
you know these are the instructions that
um
the analytical engine um
uh um would follow
and actually she had a particular
calculation she computed these
mathematical things called bernoulli
numbers
and actually it's sort of a funny story
behind those bernoulli numbers
come out from um uh working out when you
do algebra you can work out
um um the um uh the the
um you're you're working out um
various sort of products of algebraic
expressions and so on
and um you can uh you can work these out
by hand
but actually in the 1700s a chat called
bernoulli
forget which bernoulli maybe jacob
bernoulli i'm not sure there's a whole
family of mathematicians with many many
three generations of many mathematicians
and with all with last name bernoulli
but anyway one of the bernoullis
was very proud because they worked out a
sort of mathematical shortcut
for doing all of the calculations that
were needed
to come up with these uh coefficients
in these algebraic expansions and those
that sort of shortcut
uh the the condensation of that shortcut
became called bernoulli numbers
and you can compute the bernoulli
numbers using this
uh equation where the number the nth
bernoulli number
is defined in terms of earlier bernoulli
numbers for smaller values of n
so anyway ada lovelace chose the
computational bernoulli numbers as her
example
for the first program i suspect knowing
that bernoulli himself
a hundred years earlier had used it as a
dramatic shortcut for some yet longer
computation
anyway so she wanted to show that the
analytical engine could compute
bernoulli numbers and so she wrote out
the series of steps that includes some
loops and things
for doing uh for doing banoon numbers
her loops are a little bit hicky in
terms of the way they work
um actually i i tried to translate uh
ada's code into modern world from
language code and it's a little bit it
had a couple of bugs
and a little bit a little bit uh a
little bit tricky but the basic idea of
set up write out a series of abstract
instructions
that could be operated on a mechanical
device
that was something that ada lovelace
really really was the one to figure out
i mean what became necessary after that
to make a most
theoretical view was the very the idea
of a function
people learn the idea of a function when
they learn about
i guess when they learn about calculus
it's a mathematical idea it took an
incredibly long time
for people to understand the idea of a
function a function you know f
of x what does it mean it's just today
we just think well you have a program
you give it the value you know you
x is two f squares the
the the number it's given as its as its
argument and comes out with two squared
you give it three comes out with three
squared this idea of an
abstract function f which maybe you
didn't necessarily say what it does yet
you just say
it's a function and you could like say
you apply the function
f apply the function to the function f
of f of x
you can talk about the function
abstractly that idea of an abstract
function
took a really really long time to arise
in mathematics it wasn't really
clear until the end of the 1800s and
that was kind of what was necessary
for the kind of run-up to things like
ideas like turing machines
and that's not something that that um uh
existed in the time of ada lovelace
and and so that that kind of theoretical
development wasn't really possible
yet at that time but yes i think that
it's fair to say that that um
uh ada was kind of the first programmer
although
she only got to do you know what do they
call it in in modern computer science
classes um
oh gosh what is it called it's kind of a
pen and paper
uh programming not um she didn't have a
a computer to run her computation on or
she would have found that had bugs in it
i'm sure
uh those bugs might have in those days
you know the
if they had built the analytical engine
as i said it would have been a thing the
size of a large
train locomotive um and uh you know it
would have been the thing full of all
these cogs and gears and things
and you know probably a bug would
manifest itself and grind grind grind
crank crank crank
and some gear would would get sort of uh
uh
forced with you know high force and
would break a gear tooth and the whole
thing would blow up or something
that would be the dramatic version of a
of a bug back in those days
um there's a question where does the
word compute in english come from i
think in
in latin it's computo computare i think
it's uh
already exists in latin i think it means
in in
uh in ancient times it meant to reckon
to to calculate
in um uh um
in um uh you know to
to calculate out something like to to
figure out
you know oh i'm buying three sheep how
much is that if one sheep costs this
amount
how much do three sheep cost i think
that was the um the latin word for i
don't know it's it's earlier origin
i know that in in most languages you
know compute is one of the roots
ordinator
like in french it's ordinary that's a
that's a common root
um i think there are some languages i
think i think if i remember correctly
there
there are a few languages that have sort
of unique roots for the word for
computer i
think in icelandic icelandic i think is
a language which tries not to invent new
words so it has to
recycle old ones and i think the word
for computer
is um uh uh i think it's
it's it's the words for like uh wizard s
of numbers or something those two words
put together i think is this the word in
icelandic
something i don't remember but um uh for
computer
um but um
uh well okay there's a question here
um which i think i should
[Music]
about why is the von neumann
architecture for computers
still dominating so so one of the things
and this will be my last question for
today um one of the questions about a
computer is
a computer
it operates it does a series of
instructions
the program that you give a computer
says do this do this do this do this do
this
there's a question of is is there just
one stream of instructions that the
computer does
or does it get told do all these things
in parallel do all these different
calculations
or maybe maybe one part of the computer
does this another part of the computer
does that and so on and so on and so on
that's so the ordinary way of doing
things is often called serial sequential
computation do this
followed by that followed by that
followed by that the other way where
lots of things happen
all at the same time is is called
parallel computation
well uh one of the things that and so
many many modern computers i
i should say that that um uh there is a
form of parallel computation that has
become pretty common these days
which is what's done in gpus graphics
processing units
which are kind of uh things that exist
in most computers
originally developed for helping with
the graphics that would be displayed on
computers but now they're used for more
general purposes
in a gpu it is often the case that
you'll have a whole long list of numbers
and you'll do the same operation to all
those numbers but
it'll be done in parallel to all the
numbers in that list
so if you've got sort of all the pixels
representing some region on the screen
you're doing the same operation to the
values of all those pixels and that can
happen
uh sort of in in parallel in a gpu
the circuitry of a gpu is set up to be
able to do that
now a more interesting case is
you have lots of different circuitry and
and all the computers that
all the different pieces are doing
different things so it's pretty common
in modern computers to
have a multi-core cpu that means there
are
different uh that there are different
sort of pieces of the cpu that can do
different computations
but within each cpu within each core
there's typically a sequence of
instructions that are executed
and and if you look on your computer
you'll find that there your operating
system of your computer
is usually running many many different
programs but each one is sequentially
running
in one of the cores of your computer and
it may it'll run one program for a while
then it'll stop and it'll start running
another program and so on
all and you know it controls how that
works that's one of the big functions of
an operating
system but okay so the question is why
isn't it the case that one just has
computers where
lots of different things where there are
lots of different pieces to the computer
and they're all doing different
things and and somehow they all come
together to get you the answer you want
okay why isn't it done that way well it
could be done very efficiently probably
if it was done that way the big problem
is
it's really hard for us to understand
what's going on
it's hard enough for us to write
programs that work
that are sequential programs writing
parallel programs that work is even
vastly more difficult
because you have to kind of think oh if
this happened before this
well this needs the result of this thing
before it can go on
how do i get the kind of the result from
this to be ready before the result from
that
oh what happens if this other thing um
doesn't have the results from this other
thing in time
or it's going to stop it's not going to
be able to do anything until it gets
these other results
it's very hard for us to in our brains
understand how to do parallel
programming and that's the main reason
parallel programming hasn't become more
popular um
now it's an interesting question uh you
know when we do ordinary sequential
programming
the way that we can do it these days
well is
to you know the computer has certain
instructions that it's doing
we in our brains have certain ways to
think about how computation should
happen
i've spent a large part of my life
trying to build a computational language
that bridges that kind of divide between
how we think about things
and how computers do things so our
wolfram language is sort of the
the uh the highest level example of a
kind of bridge between our way of
thinking about things computationally
and what computers actually do and
actually if you look in
language there are many things there
many sort of
operations in the language which are in
effect
doing things in parallel but we think of
them
in sort of one go so for example there
might be an operation
like just just adding one to a list of
numbers okay you've got a whole list of
a million numbers
you say plus one okay it it then will
just in parallel
add one to all those million numbers
that's an easy thing for us to
understand
there are more elaborate operations i
don't know there's a operation called
folding
um that's a slightly more elaborate
operation where you're sequential where
you're
where you're accumulating things that's
something that can be done
in part in parallel there's there's all
kinds of other things that you can do in
parallel
although we managed to to encapsulate
them we managed to put them into
operations
that we can think of as sort of one lump
of computation so we don't have to
get our brains wrapped around this whole
all these parallel things happening
we can just think of it oh it's it's an
operation it does this
inside things are happening in parallel
um and even we can sometimes implement
them in parallel
on computers but for us conceptually
they're still
sequential now an interesting
challenge is is there a way of
presenting essentially a language for
computation
that can represent parallel things
in a way that we humans can really wrap
our brains around it
and i've thought about this question
since the 1980s
i worked quite a bit on a massively
parallel computer that had
60 000 processors um back in the
mid-1980s
um and it was very hard to figure out
how to program a thing like that
and uh and so but it got me thinking how
would you think about doing that kind of
thing
okay so here's the big surprise to me at
least
the things we've done in physics
recently i think finally give us a way
to potentially understand
how to do that kind of programming of
lots of things in parallel
here's why that's not so surprising
after the fact
if we think about physics we're thinking
about things happening in the universe
and we think about everything that
happens in the universe
being a little computation going on but
what's happening in the universe is
a computation is happening here another
computation is happening here
somehow those computations have to
become compatible in some way they have
to be
they have to that and but this notion of
parallel computation it's happening all
over the universe
and in fact this whole ambiguity about
what happened first what didn't happen
first
that ambiguity actually turns out to be
the essence of quantum mechanics and
physics
and in fact for people who know about
these things uh the uncertainty
principle in quantum mechanics
is basically directly related to what
are called race conditions
in uh where where two different
processes are kind of racing for which
we'll get the answer first
and and locking up until one of them has
got to the end
in parallel computing so in fact the
ideas from physics
turn out it seems to be
precisely related to did i just lose
this
ah let's see what happens here
oh that's odd
okay maybe this is still working um
anyway i was saying that that um these
ideas of parallel computing
uh turn out to be exactly what um
uh um what sort of seems to be needed in
physics
and seems to correspond to what's
happening in physics so i think
that there is an opportunity to use kind
of ideas from physics
to give us finally a way to think about
programming things in parallel it all
relates to things about reference frames
and relativity
all kinds of other things all right i
think i should wrap up here
uh thanks very much and um uh
look forward to uh going on
hopefully uh next week hope